Schön.
Guten Abend. Mein Name ist Afji. Ich bin die Dienstabende erst in der Aufnahme gestartet.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahme gespielt. Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Guten Abend. Wie heißen Sie bitte nochmal?
Mein Name ist Afji.
Was ist das für ein komischer Name? Woher kommen Sie?
Ich komme aus der Türkei. Das heißt in Deutsch Jäger.
Sie sind Frau Jägerin.
Ja, ich möchte, bevor Sie über Ihre Beschwerden erzählen, möchte ich ganz Ihnen ein paar allgemeine Fragen zu Ihrer Person stellen.
Okay.
Gerne.
Wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Karsten Fechner.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihren Vornamen und Nachname bestabieren?
Ja, natürlich. Karsten wie Karl Anton Richard, Siegfried Theodor Emil Nordwohl, Karsten.
Und danach nach Fechner Friedrich Emil Caesar Heinrich Nordpol Emil Richard. Fechner.
Fechner.
Er heißt Helfechner, oder?
Ich bin der Herrfechner, genau.
Herrfechner, wer sind Sie?
Ich bin 48 Jahre alt.
48.
Wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Der 28. November 1974.
Wie groß sind Sie und wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ich bin 2,5 m.
Und ich wiege ungefähr...
2,5 m.
2,5 m. Ja, ich muss schlagen immer meinen Kopf an der Tür an. Das ist richtig.
Und mein Gewicht sind ungefähr 125 kg.
120.
Schön von 20, ja.
Okay.
Herr Fechner, sind Sie verheiratet?
Nein, ich bin geschiedet. Ich war verheiratet.
Seit wann sind Sie geschiedet?
Seit 2 Jahren.
Wozu ist das wichtig, Frau Doktor?
Ich spiele doch keine Rolle. Ich möchte jetzt über mich reden.
Okay, Herr Fechner.
Ich rede hier über Personalien.
Ja, okay.
Was fühlt sich um Sie?
Wir können mit Ihrem Beschwerden anfangen.
Bitte darum.
Natürlich.
Was fühlt sich um Herr Fechner?
Ich habe so einen komischen Husten und so einen Druck auf der Brust seit 3 Wochen.
Es wird immer schlimmer.
Der ganze Schleim sitzt mir hier vorne auf der Brust ganz fest.
Ganz komisch.
Ich bekomme schlecht Luft jedes Mal, wenn ich mich anstrenge.
Und es wird nicht besser.
Ja, ist Sie richtig feststanden habe?
Sie haben seit 3 Wochen Brustschmerzen und Husten.
Ja, und Luftnoten.
Und Luftnoten auch.
Ja, ich merke, sobald ich kurze Strecke laufe, ich muss stehen bleiben und Luft holen.
Ist der Husten mit Ausgruf oder ohne Ausgruf?
Ja, seit einigen Tagen.
Ja, vorher nicht.
Da hatte ich wirklich nur einen Druck.
Wie ist die Farbe der Ausgruf und Konsistenz?
Ich habe der jetzt nicht nachgeguckt.
Jedes Mal, wenn ich wusste, kommt schon ein bisschen Schleim.
Ich würde dieses als C bezeichnen.
Die Farbe habe ich nicht geguckt.
Aber ich glaube, so gelblich ein bisschen.
Ja.
Und ich wusste, Sie tagtüber?
Ständig, auch in der Nacht noch mehr.
Wenn ich mich pflegen muss, dann muss ich noch mehr rüsten.
Und das sticht dann immer hier auf der Seite.
Und ich kriege dann immer so einen Druck auf der Brust.
Sie haben Brustspurzel oder in ganzem Brustspurzel?
Ja, oben sitzt das.
Strahlen die Schmerzen irgendwo hin?
Nein, es ist hier oben.
Und sind die Beschwerden lagenungsabhängig?
Zum Beispiel beim Sitzen, Stehen oder Liegen?
Dieses Druckgefühl ist eigentlich immer da.
Aber der Husten wird beim Liegen, wenn ich mich hinlege, schlimmer.
Auch jetzt, oh Gott, ich kriege echt schlecht Luft.
Wahnsinn.
Ich werde Ihre Vitalparameter kontrollieren.
Wir können eine Pauten machen.
Ich kontrolliere Ihre Sauerstoff-Sättigung.
Was ist das? Wollen Sie mir Sauerstoff geben?
Ich glaube, ich brauche jetzt echt Sauerstoff.
Ich werde auch AKG schreiben.
Wir können weiter machen.
Ich bin da, ich fühle mich schon ein bisschen besser.
Das ist gut, dass Sie besser fühlen.
Herr Fischner, haben Sie auch Herzrasen?
Ja, wo sind die Fragen, Frau Doktor?
Das bekomme ich auch immer wieder.
Insbesondere wenn ich laufe oder treppen steige.
Ich arbeite im Stall mit den Pferden.
Wenn ich da bei den Pferden bin, muss ich ein bisschen arbeiten.
Dann bekomme ich auch Herzrasen.
Ich muss immer mich hinsetzen.
Das stimmt.
Wie viele Treppe können Sie sich zeigen?
Bitte, ich habe Ihre Frage nicht.
Wie viele Treppe treppen Sie?
Ich habe nicht viel.
Nach der dritten, vierten Stufe merke ich das schon.
Ich merke auch jetzt beim Reden.
Das fällt mir auch schon sehr schwer.
Haben Sie auch Piper?
Es ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Aber ich fühle mich schon seit 2 Tagen etwas kalt.
Ich habe es nicht gemessen.
Haben Sie auch Nachtschweiß?
Ich schwitze schon in der Nacht.
Ich weiß nicht, was damit Sie meinen.
Sie wissen Sie in der Nacht der Stadt?
Nicht so oft.
Zeitweise ja, aber eigentlich nicht so.
Es ist viel mehr der Fall.
Ich habe es nicht gemessen.
Ich muss immer die Fenster aufreißen.
Ich muss mehr Luft bekommen.
Das wird immer schlimmer.
Herr Feschner, haben Sie Probleme mit dem Stuhlgang?
Nein.
Können Sie gut schlafen?
Ich habe es nicht gemacht.
Nein, bei 3 Wochen nicht.
Wir gehen sehr frustriert.
Wir gehen frustriert.
Ich bin gestern in der Brust.
Ich habe das Gefühl, schlecht Luft zu bekommen.
Ich kann nicht richtig schlafen.
Herr Feschner, machen Sie sich keine Sorge.
Sie sind in gutem Händen.
Wir machen das Beste aus allem für Sie.
Haben Sie noch irgendwelche begleitende Symptome besperrt?
Nein, ich habe alles aufgezählt.
Können Sie sich müde?
Ja, ich fühle mich kraftlos.
Sind Ihre Beine geschwollt?
Ist mir nicht aufgefallen? Nein.
Haben Sie es gemacht?
Nein.
Könnte es sein, dass Sie sich perfektiv verabschieden?
Haben Sie eine Unfall? Nein.
Nein, habe ich nicht gehabt.
Nein.
Ich hatte mal einen Sportunfall, aber das liegt 10 Jahre zurück.
Ich habe nicht gehört.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Erkrankungen,
von denen ich wissen sollte?
Ich habe einen Sportunfall,
aber das liegt 10 Jahre zurück.
Was haben Sie für eine Erkrankung,
von denen ich wissen sollte?
Ich habe einen leicht erhöhten Blutdruck,
da nehme ich Medikamente.
Welche Medikamente nehmen Sie dagegen ein?
Ich glaube, das heißt Ramipri.
Im Westen dosieren.
Ich glaube, das sind 5 Milligramm.
Eine morgens oder Abend?
Ich nehme eine morgens.
Das halten wir mal.
Ich habe sehr oft Schmerzen an der Lenden.
Ich hatte mal einen Bandschreiben vorfallen.
Das macht sich immer wieder bemerkbar.
Da muss ich in letzter Zeit sehr oft Schmerztabletten nehmen.
Schmerztabletten?
Welche Schmerztabletten nehmen Sie?
Normalerweise über Profäen.
Manchmal muss ich aber auch Thylidin nehmen.
Thylidin?
Thylidin, ja.
Vertragen Sie diese Medikamente sehr gut?
Ja, also bisher, kein Problem.
Die helfen mir auch sehr gut.
Reagieren Sie allergisch auf irgendwelche Medikamente?
Nein, ist nichts Bekanntes mehr.
Sind Sie gegen Coronavirus und Kinderkrankheiten geimpft?
Ja, ich habe schon meine 4 Infos.
Die letzte war vor 3 Monaten.
Also wir sind vollständig geimpft.
Waren Sie in der letzten Zeit im Ausland?
Was heißt in letzter Zeit?
5 Wochen war ich im Ausland.
Wir hatten einen langen Flug.
Wir waren in St.Port.
Wo?
In Singapur.
Singapur.
Das waren ca. 14 Stunden Flug.
14 Stunden.
Wir waren 10 Tage.
Wir sind vor 4 Wochen ungefähr gekommen.
Rauchen Sie Herr Fechner?
Nein.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Nein, auch nicht.
Was ist eine Routinefrage?
Nehmen Sie Drogen?
Drogen?
Was meinen Sie mit Drogen?
Ich rauche ab und zu mal Haschisch.
Also härtere Sachen habe ich jetzt nicht probiert.
Was meinen Sie mit Ab und zu?
Wenn man mit Freunden mal zusammen ist,
dann ist es einmal im Monat.
Einmal probieren.
Nein, einmal im Monat.
Gibt es irgendwelche Erkrankungen in Ihrer Familie?
Ich habe eine Erkrankung mit der Familie.
Mein Vater hatte Diabetes.
Und seit Neuestem auch in Morbus Park in Sonnen.
Diabetes Typ 1 oder 2?
2. Also ein Altersdiabetes.
Ich weiß nicht, was das für ein Typ ist.
Und seit einem Jahr ungefähr ein Morbus Park in Sonnen,
der zittert so an den Händen.
Dann geht es eigentlich ganz gut.
Die hat nichts.
Die hat aber ein bisschen Nudrung,
aber ein bisschen Kolesterolien.
Aber ich glaube, sie nimmt nichts.
Sie sind gescheitert.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Nein.
Tragen Sie Sport?
Ja.
Ich mache Fitness.
Ich bin regelmäßig im Sportstudio,
mache Kraftstraining
und fahre Fahrrad.
Herr Feschner,
haben Sie in der letzten Zeit
eine Erkältung gehabt?
Nein, jetzt also.
Ja, vor einem Monat.
Nein, nein, hatte ich nicht.
Okay, Herr Feschner, ich habe meine Fragen gestellt.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Vielen Dank.
Ich möchte noch wissen, was es ist.
Das ist so schlimm,
aber die Luft ist wirklich schlimm.
Herr Feschner,
wir haben auserst immer drei Schritte.
Zuerst das Anamnese-Gespräch,
dann für Perlische Unterzuchtung
und dann für Apparativ- und Diagnostik.
Wir haben nur das Anamnese-Gespräch durchgeführt.
Ich werde Sie körperlich untersuchen,
danach Brut abnehmen,
bei Ihnen Brut abnehmen
und Apparativ- und Diagnostik,
wie Röntgenaufnahme.
Okay, das hört sich gut an.
Ich glaube, das ist ganz gut.
Ja, Röntgenaufnahme veranlassen.
Ja, ich werde auch mit meinem Oberarzt sprechen,
wie wir weitergehen.
Ja, ich werde jetzt Ihre Vitalparameter
kontrollieren.
Vielen Dank. Sie sind ganz nett, Frau Dr. Avci.
So, wir zeichnen die Ergebnisse von den Untersuchungen.
Die, die mehr positiv.
Opponieren negativ.
Sauerstoffsetigung 80%.
Blutdruck 100%.
Bulz 110%.
Arithmic, Technik oder?
Einzelne Extrasysteme.
Dann auskultatorisch auf der Lunge.
Pulmonal, linksbasal, wenig Atemgericht.
Atemgeräusche, feuchte Rasselgeräusche.
Liebbenzehrenose.
Ja, die anamnestischen und klinischen Ankabend
deuten am ehesten auf eine Lungenembolie hin.
Jetzt machen wir die Arztübergabe und dann sagen Sie Ihre Diagnose.
Hallo, Kollegen, andere Fragen?
Keine Fragen.
Nein, hatten Sie so etwas früher schon einmal?
Nein.
Wie viel gibt es Menschen, die schlafen?
Ich kann in letzter Zeit gar nicht schlafen, mich sehr erzielt.
Okay.
Haben Sie Österdottbillen oder Soires aufgestoßen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Haben Sie Schluckbechwerden?
Nein.
Wie hoch ist der Dima?
Der Dimaere?
Ja.
Wir haben erst mal nur einen Schnelltest gemacht, der ist positiv.
Also das Ergebnis vom Labor steht noch raus.
Eine Frage, sind Sie beschwerd pröselt sich oder langsam aufgezählt?
Langsam? Seit drei Wochen.
Im Laufe der Zeit sind Sie beschwerd, wer schlecht hat?
Ja, deswegen bin ich da.
Okay.
Sie haben gut gemacht, indem Sie rechtzeitig gegessen sind.
Das sind drei Wochen natürlich, da geht es nicht.
Normalerweise denkt man leicht erkehrt und es geht wieder vorbei,
aber das ist immer schlimmer geworden.
Okay, soll man die Diagnose sagen, Herr Doktor,
oder soll man erst mal eine Übergabe, ein Oberarzt machen?
Nein.
Ich habe zwei Zwei-Fälle-Machungen gegeben,
und dann geht es direkt um die Ferdachdiagnose
und die Transparenz.
Okay.
Die Anamnestische angaben durch die Ästchen
auf eine Nundenembole hin.
Als Differenz der Diagnosen kommen Pynomony und
Okay, also die Diagnose?
Lungen ödem, Lungen ödem, auch ja.
Die Diagnose, eine infarkt Pynomony bei Lungenemony.
Okay, also bei den.
Ein infarkt Pynomony, nennt sich das.
Also eine Pynomony nach einer Lungenembolie.
Das ist richtig.
Pynomony nach einer Lungenembolie.
Infarkt auch.
Das nennt sich infarkt Pynomony.
Also das ist kein Herzinfarkt, sondern eine infarkt Pynomony.
Okay.
Genau, als Differenzialdiagnose kommen natürlich erstmal eine Pynomony.
Und Kardial, was kann es Kardial sein?
Kardial, Perikati.
Vorhin kamen die Beispiele, ein Lungen ödem bei einer Kardialen D-Kompensation.
Lungen ödem.
Haben Sie verstanden, Frau Avji?
Ja, ja, ich habe verstanden, aber ich weiß jetzt nicht.
Was wissen Sie nicht?
Fragen Sie doch.
Ja, ja, ich weiß aber, ich kann mich nicht gut erinnern.
Ja, jetzt Herzinsuffizienz.
Herzinsuffizienz kann eine Lungenödem machen, ein Herzinfarkt,
kann eine Lungenödem machen.
Viele Erkrankungen können eine Lungenödem machen.
Oder eine Kardiale D-Kompensation bedeutet, dass ein Herzproblem,
egal welcher Art, kann eine Lungenödem auslösen.
Das kann ein Klappenfehler sein, eine Metralklappeninsuffizienz kann es sein.
Eine Endokarditis kann sowas machen.
Eine Myokarditis kann das machen.
Eine Herzinsuffizienz, eine Herzrhythmusstörung kann über eine Arithmie z.B.
eine Tachymöopathie machen.
Das heißt, es kommt zu einer Herzinsuffizienz und dadurch zu einem Lungenödem.
Also es gibt viele Möglichkeiten.
Klar, eine Kardiomyopathie, die sich akut verschlechtert hat.
Es gibt eine dilatative Kardiomyopathie, es gibt eine ischemische Kardiomyopathie.
Alle Kardialen Ursachen können ein Lungenödem auslösen.
Und dass eine Differenzialdiagnose der Patient gibt,
gibt auch Druck auf den Brustan.
Das heißt, ich muss immer ein Herzinfarkt,
ein Myokardinfarkt ausschließen.
Das gehört immer dazu.
Woran muss ich noch denken, wenn ich Druck auf den Brust habe?
Welche Differenzialdiagnose?
Myokarditis.
Myokarditis, haben wir schon gesagt.
Richtig, da war ein Beispiel, ein Pneumotorax.
Spontanpneumotorax, normalen Pneumotorax, genau.
Was noch, Frau Doktor?
Du musst ein Bildschirm angucken.
Ja, ja, auch die Sechsie.
Genau, auch in der Sechsie.
Auch kommt in Frage.
Eine Prioritis, genau.
Man muss auch immer an die Wirbelsäule denken.
Wenn ich ein Problem an der Brustwirbelsäule habe,
dann kann es vorne auch ein Druckgefühl auslösen.
Was war ein Problem?
Auf der Wirbelsäule kann so schwer werden.
Wirbelsäule, Praktur.
Praktur, sehr gut.
Was in der Wirbelsäule, das stimmt,
das haben wir noch gar nicht gedacht.
Speiseröhren, Probleme.
Was an der Wirbelsäule war,
muss ich denken, kann auch mal Schmerzen auslösen.
Ja, Wandschreibe und Vollfall.
Was noch?
Ich hatte eine Jungmetastasen.
Noch Metastasen an der Wirbelsäule.
Ich hatte eine junge Patientin, die war Anfang Mitte 40.
Man hat als Erstes die Metastase an der Brustwirbelsäule festgestellt.
Und was war das?
Sie hatte ein Pankeraskarzinom.
Aber die hatte mehr Schmerzen.
Das wäre auch eine sehr weite Griffe.
Differenzialdiagnose.
Ösevergittis, Gasdrittis, Ösevergittis.
Das gehört dazu.
Oder ein Divertikel.
Ein Zänker.
Sehr gut.
Jetzt haben wir die Frau Doktor sehr gequält.
Sie haben das sehr gut gemacht.
Ja, ich bin ein bisschen aufgeregt.
Ja, aber Sie haben das ganz gut gemacht.
Das war schon sehr gut.